hi i'm nitin verma
a post doctoral researcher at the
university of haifa
today i will talk about our paper query
complexity lower bounds for local list
decoding and hardcore predicates
and this is joint work with noga ranzevi
and ranin chaltiam
here is an outline of the talk i will
first define the notions of list
decoding
and local list decoding
i will then give an overview of our main
results
and the applications of our results to
black box proofs for hardcore predicates
i will then move on to give a high level
idea of our lower bound argument
which is based on a famous coin problem
i will conclude the talk with some open
problems
a binary code enc that maps bit strings
of length k
to bit strings of length n is half minus
epsilon comma
l list decodable if
for every word w which is a bit string
of length
n there are at most
l messages m such that the hamming
distance between
w and the encoding of m is
at most half minus epsilon times n
in other words there are at most l code
words
such that w can be obtained from the
code
word by flipping at most half minus
epsilon fraction of the bits
we will refer to this quantity half
minus epsilon as the fraction of errors
now a locally list decodable code is a
list decodable code
with the additional feature that
there exists an algorithm which we call
the decoder
such that for every word w
and every message m such that the
distance between w
and the encoding of m is at most half
minus epsilon times n
with probability at least two thirds
over the random coins of the decoder
there exists an advice j such that the
decoder
given oracle access to w and inputs i
comma j outputs the ith bit
of the message with probability at least
two thirds
here the advice j can be thought of as
the index to the list element
corresponding to encoding of the message
m
the number of queries made by the
decoder to the word w
is called the query complexity of the
decoder
we study local list decodability of
codes with high encoding lengths
a rather very low rate
a candidate example is the hadamard code
for those of you you are not familiar
the hadamard code
maps bit strings of length k to those of
length 2 to the k
the bit position indexed by the string r
in 0 1 to the k is the dot product mode
2
the message m and the string r
hadamard code has an efficient localized
decoder as shown by the
seminal result of goldrich 11.
for fraction of errors of half minus
epsilon
they achieve list size and query
complexity
quadratic in 1 over epsilon which is
really small
the question we ask is whether the query
complexity bound can be improved
supposing we allow for large list sizes
say of the order of 2 to the big of k
we ask this question for arbitrarily
lower rate codes and not just for
hadamard
the motivation for considering such a
question
comes from the use of goldrich 11
theorem to obtain
hardcore predicates from one-way
functions that are hard to invert
and an improvement in query complexity
of hadamard localist decoding
could mean an improvement in these type
of results
in our work we give lower bounds on the
query complexity of local list decoding
low rate codes when the value of epsilon
is large
say 1 over poly k
we show that the query complexity is
omega 1 over epsilon square
this is a tight lower bound as evidenced
by the matching upper bound
of the gold rack 11 theorem additionally
our lower bound rules out the
possibility
that allowing for large lists
might improve the query complexity
our work extends the work of greenberg
shaltiel and viola
who proved the same bound for binary
codes of higher rate
in particular the result of
greenbergital
does not cover the case of hadamard
when epsilon is smaller than one over
poly k
we prove the slightly weaker bound of
one over square root epsilon
and these two results together rule out
the question of whether the query
complexity
can be one over epsilon to the whole
power of little of one
even for low rate codes and even if we
allow
huge list sizes
one of the consequences of our result is
in an application of the gold rush 11
theorem
for obtaining hardcore predicates
the gold reich 11 theorem can be
restated as follows
in this setting
assume that f is a hard function such
that for circuits of size
s they cannot invert f
with probability more than rho
for the purpose of the talk maybe we can
assume that f is a permutation
now based on f let us define
another one-way function f new that
concatenates the output of f on the
first argument
with that of the second argument so fnu
takes two arguments
we also define a predicate f bread that
also takes two arguments x and r
and outputs the r bit
of the hadamard encoding of x
goldrich levin theorem implies that
given as input the evaluation of
f nu on an input it is impossible
for circuits of size at most roughly
s prime is equal to s over q to compute
the value of f
bread which is really a single bit with
advantage of more than epsilon or random
guessing
for concreteness assume that the
function f
is hard to invert for circuits of size
poly k
and again assume that the probability
that
the circuit c is successful
in inverting with probability at one
over poly k
rho is one over poly k
then gold rank 11 theorem guarantees
that the predicate
f bread cannot be predicted with an
advantage
of more than one over poly k over random
guessing
now suppose we start from a function
f that has a much smaller probability of
successfully
being inverted that is f is a much much
harder function
do we get any improvement on this
epsilon
this is a question that can be asked
no as we
begin with the circuit of size s is
equal to poly k
we really cannot get epsilon less than
one over s
which is equal to one over poly k
and even if you do not follow the
computation
the gist is that lldc's
with query complexity q is equal to
1 over epsilon to the theta of 1
do not help us to obtain a hardcore
predicate
for rho
as even as small as 2 to the minus
square root k
and there is no advantage over a row
with 1 over poly k
one can ask whether it is possible to
obtain a better epsilon
by replacing the hadamard with another
less decodable code
and the answer again is no because by
our theorem for
smaller epsilon this is impossible
even if we use codes with low rate and
large lists
but maybe we could do it via some other
black box technique
instead of this localized decoding
technique
again the answer is no and we show that
this is impossible for a general
definition of black box techniques the
details are in our paper
the proof technique we use here is an
extension
of the technique used for the lower
bound for small epsilon
in the rest of the talk i will focus
on showing our query lower bound on
local list decoding
for the small epsilon case even
for low rate codes and even when
allowing large
list sizes
the main idea in our proof is inspired
from a work of
apple bomitol where they show
limitations on non-deterministic
reductions
that establish hardness amplification
the first step is to reduce to a
slightly different decoding problem
and then show a lower bound on the query
complexity of that problem
just for clarity i have kept a schematic
diagram
of localis decoding on the left pane of
the slide
instead of wanting to decode from
arbitrary words
in this new problem we require
that first a message is sampled
uniformly at random
encoded with the error correcting code
and then xored with a string of length
n string z of length n where each bit in
z
is 1 independently with probability
half minus 2 epsilon we denote this
distribution
by bsc n half minus epsilon or 2 epsilon
now earlier the requirement was to
correctly output each bit of the message
with a certain probability
we change that requirement
to a new requirement of having to decode
a fraction a very large fraction of
message bits correctly
for those who are familiar this
relaxation is in line with
approximate localist decoding
we also observe that given these two
requirements
it is enough to consider deterministic
decoders
the claim we make here is that local
list decoding
implies this above the coding task
albeit
up to small losses in query complexity
so here is the renewed schematic diagram
for this somehow randomized noise
approximate local less decoding task
the second ingredient in our proof is
that of
lower bounds on the sizes of ac0
circuits solving a famous coin problem
ac 0 circuits for those of whom you are
unfamiliar
are circuits of and or are not gates
where the gates can have unbounded fan
in
now the theorem is that we use is that
if such a circuit of depth d can
distinguish
between uh bsc distribution with coins
of bias half minus epsilon
versus bse distribution with uniformly
random coins
then that circuit
has to have size roughly one over
epsilon
to the all d minus one whole power d
minus 1.
now this result follows from a long
sequence of works
and we use this theorem in the following
way
basically for a given message m
we develop a circuit c m
that on input z outputs
one if the decoder the ec
upon oracle access to encoding of
m xord with z can decode the bits of the
message
m correctly and output 0 otherwise
or precisely so we describe an ac 0
circuit that does the following
our circuit is hardwired with
the message m and also the encoding of m
it first computes encoding of m
xor with z which it receives as input
then it checks whether the deterministic
query decoder the easy
outputs the correct answer for each of
the
kl many possible input combinations i
and j these logical conditions
are stored in bits b i j specifically
b i j is equal to 1 if decoder
on access to w and inputs i and j
outputs mi
now for each value of advice j for the
decoder
the circuit computes the conjunction of
the bits bij
and this conjunction indicates whether
every bit of m is decoded correctly
when this particular j is given as input
the final output is an or over these
bits obtained for different js
essentially the output represents
whether
there exists a j for which every message
bit
is decoded correctly
we argue that it is possible to perform
these operations using an ac0 circuit of
depth 3
and size big of k l 2 to the q
where q is the query complexity of the
decoder
the key idea is that our decoder is
deterministic
and can be represented by a q times 2 to
the q
sized circuit the main issue
might appear to some of you to be
the hard wiring of the whole of encoding
of the message
m which might take n bits right
but we do not really need to do that we
only need to hardwire
those bits of encoding of m that are
queried
by the decoder on various input
combinations
and the number of such bits is not too
large
specifically it is only kl times q
2 to the q useful bits
okay so we have an efficient circuit
checking whether our decoder decodes
correctly
by definition of this new decoding task
if the input z is coming from bse half
minus epsilon
then the decoder succeeds and the
circuit cm
outputs one
on the other hand if the input z
is coming from bse half then
the encoding of m the message m
x or z will look like
is actually a uniformly random string
and
cm the circuit can decode it correctly
only with a really really small
probability
by finally by an averaging argument
and using the fact that list sizes are
still bounded by
small constant times two to the k
and an amplification of the
probabilities
we are able to show that there exists a
message m
and the corresponding circuit cm
that really solves the coin problem
using this conclusion um
and in combination with the lower bound
on the size
of circuits for the coin problem
we can obtain a lower bound expression
by appropriate simplification we get an
expression for the query complexity
so here is the theorem again
whose proof idea we outlined in
particular we
say that local list decoding
of codes from half minus epsilon
fraction of errors
need omega 1 over root epsilon queries
when epsilon is small even
if the code has very low rate and
even if we allow very large list sizes
our work leaves several open problems
one immediate open problem is to improve
the lower bound for the small epsilon
case from one over root epsilon
to maybe something better
our lower bound for the large epsilon
case can be extended
to handle decoding from erasures
uh specifically decoding from one minus
epsilon fraction of erasures
requires a bound of omega 1 over epsilon
we do not immediately see it is not
clear whether
the same can be done for the small
epsilon case
so what can we say about the small
epsilon case for
decoding from a ratios
a third very interesting question
would be whether non-black box
techniques can help
obtain better hardcore predicates from
heart functions
i would like to bring your attention to
the fact that
our work rolls out only
black box techniques and not non-black
box techniques
so this is a very interesting open
direction
in any case that is all i have got to
say
thank you for your time thank you